Let the battle begin.
With the arrival of director Todd Phillips'
long-awaited Joker movie, a new challenger
has entered the arena in hopes of becoming
the new Best Joker Actor Ever.
His name?
Joaquin Phoenix.
His game?
Well, doing his job and delivering the chilling
kind of performance he knows is required of
him, but possibly also dethroning the late
Heath Ledger in the process.
Since the announcement of Joker, fans have
pit Phoenix and Ledger against one another,
placing bets on whether or not the newcomer
could shock and scare audiences as the failed-comedian-turned-crazed-killer
Arthur Fleck as much as Ledger did through
his turn in Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight.
The debate over Phoenix and Ledger as the
Joker began months ago, but with the world
finally able to see Phoenix strut his stuff
in clown makeup and a tattered suit, the fight
is no longer theoretical.
So, now that Joker has landed in theaters,
who played the character better: Joaquin Phoenix
or Heath Ledger?
Plenty of people were totally floored by the
work Phoenix did in Joker, so much so that
they now consider him better in the role than
the late Ledger.
Some even think Phoenix is the best Joker
actor point blank.
"Are you having any negative thoughts?"
"All I have are negative thoughts."
One Twitter user wrote:
"With all due respect to previous Jokers and
to the great Heath Ledger, Joaquin Phoenix
is the best Joker.
He has everything it needs.
We finally have a proper actor playing the
character in a very unfamiliar new shape.
If Ledger's a straight flush, Phoenix's a
full deck."
Another fan tweeted:
"I thought it would take a long time before
someone delivers Joker better than Heath Ledger.
As it turned out it only took 11 years and
a certain Joaquin Phoenix."
This fan continued to gush over Phoenix's
performance in another tweet, writing,
"Joaquin Phoenix should get an Oscar, a golden
globe, an Olympic gold medal, a Nobel prize,
a ballon d'or, Knighthood, a champions league
winner medal and a presidential medal of freedom
for his performance as the joker."
Bollywood news & gossip site KoiMoi.com aimed
to settle the debate once and for all.
Their breathless verdict?
Phoenix wins, hands down:
"Phoenix's portrayal of Arthur Fleck is going
to be remembered for a lifetime.
His portrayal is so powerful that after the
film was over I was so sucked into his world
that I felt like I needed a good sleep.
Phoenix's performance makes you feel sorry
for being a part of this society and hence
I say…Joaquin Phoenix'[s] Joker makes Heath
Ledger's Joker even more badass than he was!"
But, alas, there can be no Phoenix-Joker-lovers
without Phoenix-Joker-detractors.
In the outlet's comprehensive ranking of every
Joker, Polygon placed Ledger several spots
higher than Phoenix, with Ledger coming in
second place behind Mark Hamill, who voiced
the Ace of Knaves on Batman: The Animated
Series, and Phoenix coming in fifth just ahead
of Suicide Squad actor Jared Leto.
Polygon's Susana Polo said of Phoenix's turn
as the iconic comic villain:
"His Arthur Fleck is impossible to look away
from, even when you desperately want to.
Phoenix sways, grimaces, shuffles, and delivers
terrible, involuntary paroxysms of laughter
even as he openly weeps.
He just does it in service of a character
who isn't particularly Joker-like, other than
in the most superficial ways."
Comparatively, Polygon's Patrick Willems wrote
that Ledger delivered a performance, quote,
"so good it's worth forgiving it for all the
terrible Halloween costumes and cosplays it
inspired."
"Wanna see a magic trick?
I'm gonna make a pencil... disappear."
On a different note, Jesse Hassenger of The
Week wrote that Phoenix's version of the Joker
falls short of not only the magnitude of Ledger's
iteration, but also that of the power of every
Joker actor who preceded him.
Hassenger wrote:
"Even an actor as gifted as Joaquin Phoenix
struggles with this.
Todd Phillips' new Joker is a vastly more
focused, disciplined undertaking than something
like Suicide Squad, with a committed and often
mesmerizing performance from Phoenix.
Yet it still often feels more like a composite
of influences than a real original...This
is all very well-performed by Phoenix; it's
also more indebted to Jokers past than the
movie seems to understand.
The movie wants desperately to make the Joker
feel real and resonant, and Phoenix does his
best.
But ultimately, this may mark another transition
for the Joker: a turning point from prestige
role to party trick."
With so many different versions of the Joker
in existence, no singular take on the iconic
villain can be universally heralded as the
best.
There really is no "best" Joker actor, it's
entirely subjective.
That said, being able to find even a little
bit of greatness in each of them just shows
how iconic the Clown Prince of Crime really
is.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.